let's jump into this first story and i'm
using the daily beast on purpose
because the daily beast as you know is
fake news the daily beast
so this is let me slow down here's the
story cops still can't explain agonizing
hour long wait to storm uvaldi classroom
distraught parents can be seen literally
collapsing into themselves and wailing
in anguish as officers refuse to answer
their pleas to storm the building
we hear about all the time from from
conservatives a good guy with a gun can
stop a bad guy with a gun not when the
police
are being bad guys with guns right when
they're using their authority and their
power to stop you stop a parent from
going and saving their kids when they
went save their kids one mother was able
to go in and save her kids now now i
want to point this out
i'm using the daily beast because they
are fake news
the daily beast is certified by
newsguard as fake news proceed with
caution this website fails to adhere to
several basic journalistic standards
shocker
i mean honestly it is because you'd
think the daily beast is an
establishment outlet they'd get cover
from everyone and be they were called
real news for a long time no they're
fake news you are fake news daily beast
but when even the daily beast fake news
is pointing out what was going on there
and that cops weren't letting people in
we got a weird story i mean something's
something's weird i know what you guys
think
so look
i got to go to the daily beast too
because
when i cracked the russia gate code
running the investigation from chairman
nunes back in 2017-2018
the daily beast outed me as a staffer
and wrote a whole hit piece on me which
is unheard of when you're a staffer
you're not an actual member of congress
you're just working there
and they called me a genocidal dictator
so i agree with you the daily beast is
fake news because
i'm not a genocidal dictator i'm just
the son of a man who fled from a
genocidal dictator relation uh regime
overseas so who was able to get me out
there what dictatorship did he flee from
idiomine in uganda wow yeah why did they
actually use the words genocidal oh yeah
and they called and they called me tork
mata
what's that
the guy from the spanish inquisition who
was a genocidal dictator who like
slaughtered millions of people and why
because you were calling out fake news
well because i was reporting that you
know we have proven hillary clinton you
know paid for it the campaign we were
getting going and it was big news and
they were like we're gonna take this guy
out i didn't think anything would
actually come of it but then there was
there's been a million pieces after that
but they started here well so so what do
you guys think about what was going on
with the with you know these parents
this seems weird to me right well i will
point out some people have said look you
don't want a bunch of angry and confused
parents rushing into a building it can
get chaotic especially if there aren't
i had a moment of empathy when i was
watching the video and i heard the
screaming parents where it was just like
if i was that and all of a sudden i felt
like because of bureaucracy i don't have
a chance to save my kid and then find
out that the kid was killed is like
i like the cops are doing what they were
instructed to do which is don't let the
people run inside they might get hurt
they might cause more damage
but my god when the when the when it
hits the fan it's like
the rules are off when when your
children's lives are at stake
and you need to do what you got to do to
save their lives
that's that was hard to watch i was
reading about this and i was like i
literally cannot imagine what it'd be
like to stand there and think that my
kid literally might die within the next
few seconds if i wasn't to jump in and
do something about it and for the cops
to stand there and to tell me not to go
in
i would lose it i wouldn't be able to
would be responsible for my actions i
spoke with somebody earlier who said
that he had had some contacts on the
ground and the reason for the delay is
that they were so the shooter had gone
into the building and they were sort of
establishing what their protocols were
going to be for for breaching which is a
little different than this story because
now we come to find out that police
actually took the time to go and save
their own kids but didn't allow parents
to go in to say theirs it didn't make
any real effort to save anybody else's
and i think that's it's sort of a
travesty you know and this isn't the
only situation that we've had with the
school shooting where
there was a huge delay in terms of a
police response you know with parkland
police were told to stand down there was
a long delay before any action was taken
you got one guy in there with a gun and
then you got what dozens of people
outside it seems like there would be
some sort of protocol in place that
would allow them to be able to go in
and and do something
yeah i mean that's the thing with law
enforcement right coming from a law
enforcement background
you want your cop that's what you that's
why they sign up to go in there not yeah
you establish a perimeter all that stuff
but if there's a school shooting you
know get some bodies in there doing
something and i think that's the biggest
complaint you got to wait for the
investigation to come out because it's
going to take forever to get everything
right but
my biggest question is why weren't there
a couple cops in there right away that
like why you guys think that cops should
have be armed or not cops rather i'm
sorry i was like
that's not what i meant to ask
teachers teachers do you think the
teachers should be armed in these
schools i think teachers want to be
armed why not if because obviously
they're going to have to go through some
sort of training you know you can't just
carry um but if somebody wants to care
if they're if they've proven that
they're able to be responsible and that
they have demonstrated a certain level
of proficiency with a firearm and
they're able to protect kids you know if
they're carrying concealed nobody's
going to know which teachers are
carrying and which which aren't i'm not
i'm not i'm not for
forcing any teacher who doesn't want to
carry to carry but if you have somebody
who
is open to the idea and they want to be
that person and they could be somebody
that interdicts a situation like this um
i don't see any reason why we should not
allow that
simple answer yes
it's it's not a question of teachers
it's a question of people i think people
should be armed that's it yeah 100 yeah
well i was uh workshopping this idea
earlier today that i think that the only
way to fix this gun problem that we have
in the u.s is to do it from the ground
up that means a cultural change that
means someone who's going into a school
or someone who's going in to rob a store
they don't know if the person they're
about to rob or the person they're about
to attack is going to be armed and
that's going to significantly dampen
their enthusiasm for doing extremely
critical criminal activities obviously
that's not something that the government
can enforce and we need to like have a
serious respect for guns but i know i
hope we could get there i don't think
so so right now the one thing that
really bugs me about the whole
the whole issue is there's no real
conversation
uh particularly from the left on um
solving these things they just
they complain about people saying
thoughts and prayers well i don't think
thoughts and prayers are solving any of
the problems either it's just kind of
like you know i feel for you which is it
i don't get a problem with it it's just
you know okay great you know sympathy
empathy the left then comes out gets
angry and says i'm sorry i'm sorry i
gotta stop not the left the liberals the
left it's like guns you know leftists
are more revolutionary they like guns
the liberals are like we need background
checks and i'm like okay we got those
what's next and they're like no no we
need background checks i'm like okay we
have those that already happens what's
next
i don't think you know we hear not from
the right is like we should arm the
teachers
that's not going to solve anything
either and i'll tell you why it may it
may prevent
because some of these guys some of these
these psychopaths might be like a
teacher could be armed that i that i
agree with but in this circumstance
cops were there
good guys with guns were there the
parents were good guys with guns the
cops were and the cops actually impeded
it the cops were supposed to be the good
guys with guns they stopped it you look
at parkland that's security guard didn't
he run away
he got in trouble for that
so i'm saying
i think we have deep seated cultural
problems
where
you know you guys see beto o'rourke
yeah heckle the press conference on on
these kids and and i'm seeing you know
democrat activists cheer for this and
i'm just like come on man choose your
battles but that's what beto did
is a contributing factor to why lunatics
do this they know that you're going to
get barack obama that you're going to
get beto o'rourke and they will scream
your name out to the world with your
picture
so they that that's what they're
thinking they're thinking this is how
people will finally know who you are
because they're they're sick they're
nuts i think everybody agrees jordan
peterson tweeted out earlier that we
should not be saying the names of these
criminals these killers just just don't
because that's what the big part of it
is they want to be famous they want it
to be their final hurrah and then if
they see names get shouted out that my
copycats might come up and do the same
thing
i thought it means i thought it was a
good point yeah you know some some
people have mentioned what we need is
cruel and unusual punishment for these
people and i'm like well you can't do
that under the constitution right but
this is their argument is
do something such a way that humiliates
them and makes them not want that the
dude that ran up on dave chappelle with
a knife uh like a gun with a fake gun
with a knife in it yeah they broke his
arms or his hand i mean that was cruel
and unusual what they did to that guy
well he no
you could say he had it coming and
deserved it i think i think you know you
run up on stage at a guy that's a knife
you're gonna get your butt your body
broken but that's not that's not cruel
and unusual cruel and unusual is like a
stockade you know like taking somebody
chucking stones at someone yeah yeah or
you know burying them up to their neck
and then having everybody walk by and
piss on them is crawling which isn't it
if you can if you can like hold them and
secure them then if you kick them while
they're down that's cruel and unusual
this guy
no no no that's not so uh you can argue
cruelty if it's excessive but occurs of
force is not legal in the case of the
guy with chappelle i think his arm got
dislocated because they tackled him
they like they all jumped up and pinned
him and dropped him on the ground and
his arm got messed up in the scuffle if
you attack someone and someone is using
force to stop you when you get hurt
that's not cruel and unusual if we
capture these people and then like i
said you bury them up to their neck and
dirt and then everyone can walk over and
spit on them that is cruel and unusual
people have argued for like uh one of
the memes that goes around is this it's
a liberal guy who posted this or people
who post this calling them like you know
tiny peepee shooter and giving them
these weird names so that forever in
history they won't be known by their
name but by an insult
i don't know if that actually would work
but i get the idea and i think they're
scratching at the surface of the problem
these people know that every politician
everyone's going to say they're not
going to say this guy's name i'm not
going to mention i'm going to show his
picture
you know but the media does all day
every day and people tweet about them
and that's what they know they get i'm
reminded of the oobliet the uh the
ancient middle middle ages uh punishment
it was just basically a pit an obliet
means to forget and they would take
criminals and they would if they throw
them in the pit and that was it never
mentioned their name again maybe they
got fed who knows yo that's one way to
do it jeez
it's harsh that was that was rough yeah
i don't think it's coming back though
unfortunately i doubt it budweiser would
probably sponsor it but um maybe
maybe the suspension in the pit yeah man
let's do it
i don't know those people that that on
january 6th there's people in solitary i
don't know if that's really an obliette
but that's people that's solitary that's
basically it i mean look i was a public
defender back in the day and i argued
for some of the worst people in humanity
because they need to due process and the
same thing it's like okay should you
have a bond should you have a bond while
you're waiting trial presumed innocent
and look whatever your political
positions are on january 6 and whether
it should or shouldn't have happened if
you have a 60 year old grandmother who
has never committed a crime in solitary
confinement or not given bond there's
something wrong with that situation that
means the judiciary has been politicized
and you're a year on from january 6 and
you have 50 plus people
without bond many in solitary
confinement i mean all that does is
makes them want to plead and get out
plead guilty not have the constitutional
protections of due process and the
presumption of innocence and the right
to counsel they just want to rack up
political victories i think that's my
interpretation of what this committee's
doing i i think that the january 6
people is as close as you can get to
cruel and unusual
with without jumping over the line in an
obvious way keeping people locked up
keeping them in solitary doing these
things is like you mentioned it's it's
effectively torturing them
so you can get them to just give up
that's it and it's all politically
motivated too so it causes people to not
have any faith in the system which
ultimately is bad for the country as a
whole
it's terrible i mean
i've argued both sides federal
prosecutor federal public defender and
i've just never seen any situation where
you just blatantly chuck a bunch of
people i've gotten murderers and rapists
out who are charged with those crimes on
bond
because it was the actual right thing to
do based on the facts and the judge made
a decision you have people here with no
criminal history who didn't commit a
violent act and they're being held
detained it's thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there